building drawers playing Vsauce Kevin
here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people
this is bdp building michael grab
assemble sculptures out of rocks using
only gravity they're meant to evoke all
and disbelief surrounding the forces of
nature as well as illustrate what can be
accomplished with delicacy and patience
the series is called gravity glue and
you can watch him assemble the Zen
garden like projects on his YouTube
channel shouldn't reach azúcar sculpts
intricate animals that are also
lollipops amaze iku is a traditional art
from Japan in which heated taffy is
sculpted with tweezers and scissors and
then painted the taffy cools within
minutes oh it must be crafted as
efficiently as possible
Tezuka is the only Ami's iku artist in
japan who uses gradation to color his
candy but he holds classes to teach
others his unique style puzzles on
tonight all Mirai can I borrow plate the
hole pushing out the wall
midnight tonight blushing on each Kippur
built an endlessly churning whirlpool
the project is called dissension and is
meant to evoke the feelings of
discomfort we experienced when
confronted with empty spaces the first
iteration of the project was installed
in India but in may another one was
built in an abandoned Italian movie
theater Veronica Richter over repurposes
plastic bottles into plants she heats
the bottles up carves and attaches them
to other bottles in order to create
everything from colorful cacti to
intricate chandeliers she has a
fascination with plastic and not only
collects it but also has written
extensively on its history and usage
Oscar Dory builds Transformer toys out
of candy boxes which is just really cool
here's a caramel box that turns into a
robot and this horse turns into a tank
draw David's Briggs creates 3d images by
layering sheets of engraved or painted
glass this piece titled the Sun King
depicts a police officer in riot gear
and is based off of a Roman statue
destroyed during the French Revolution
Spriggs is interested in the
relationship between state power and its
faceless enforcers which is why the
subject is 20 feet tall and its face is
obscured from every angle
Xavier paints the desert with light
using light-up cacti he wanted to create
an uncontrollable and erratic world and
then let the viewer interpret their own
personal narrative as they watch the
film find the link below to watch the
whole incredible video
and now for the organic globular
surrealist art work of chun-yan me fly
it when Solomon is an inventor as well
as a one-man orchestra he built his
majestic bellow phone in 1983 and it's
comprised of playground balls coat
hanger wire vacuum parts and plumbing
pipes dance crews unite to form a XYZ M
a company that specializes in movement
design here's their first video which
combines body movement props and
patterns
together our alone by eternal summers
features stop-motion using found objects
directed by Jaffe riddle
inspiration also comes from you Vsauce
creative fan showcase first up is zoo
legacy which shall never fall in love
let's go
William handcrafts custom stamps on his
Etsy page subliming sensation the
versatile stamps work with wood-burning
leather burning and soap melting and he
also has a huge variety of custom glass
work janelle creates a wide variety of
step-by-step nail art tutorials on her
youtube channel
elle and dish she creates pop culture
characters using nail stamping as well
as making her own stickers using
sandwich bags and templates check out
her channel to learn how to do this and
let's Haun of other stuff here's Carter
with almost 9
Danielle Sullivan's regrowth is an
installation using books to create a
garden including flowers pebbles and
even a shed each item was hand folded
and it took two months to complete
Ruba art is a collection of friends in
Poland making portraits out of Rubik's
cubes including Marilyn Monroe and a
lion
submit your bidipis bdp at Vsauce comm
or share them with everyone on Twitter
with hashtag bdp if you need even more
inspiration check out guys show on we
sauce this world of ours a laid-back
look at some of the sweetest submissions
by real vsauce fans and as always thanks
for watching
then they slice by the night cucumber
cuts up on front of us without the crust
then cut in one
Hey
all honor days oh my legs
Oh
ruff
Oh